the biggest news in the world apart from
the pandemic that's running right
outside Joe Rogan moving to Spotify so
anybody who doesn't know what's going on
Joe Rogan has signed an exclusive long
year deal multi-year deal probably three
or four years with Spotify the rumored
amount was a hundred mil now I don't
know if that's 100 mil a year or a
hundred mil total but either way it's a
significant amount of money it's the
largest amount of money that a podcast
has ever been paid for a platform
exclusive and I think that there's
probably quite a lot of implications for
what's going on here so I'll give you a
little bit of background Rogen announces
that he's moving the entire podcast to
Spotify every old episode will remain on
YouTube on Apple podcasts stitcher
wherever else you tuned in but from the
end of the year it will be new episodes
will only exist on Spotify and Spotify
going to create a video platform
exclusive like create a video hosting
platform in the Joe well I'm presuming
they will roll it out thereafter but
like on Apple podcasts at the moment you
can actually create video podcasts Brian
Rose breakdancing inside well while we
we did it ages ago but it rounds your
your allowance your storage up here on
your on your hosting platform so yeah
spot if I say that they're going to do
that
Oliver oguns old stuff but this means no
more YouTube it means no more Apple
podcasts he will continue to upload some
clips to YouTube on the JR Eclipse
channel which is good I guess for him
for the searchability virality people
discovering the podcast but full
episodes the only place that you can get
them for presumably the next couple of
years at the very least is going to be
Spotify that audio and video and then
the he announced that the Spotify share
price closed eight percent up that night
and then the next day did another 10
percent so Spotify paid what is rumored
he hasn't said it's what if I paid
around about 100 mil for Joe Rogan and
increased their market cap by five
billion that's a
and times return five good move 500 500
no 50 yeah Oh God million yes or no best
or not whatever weights because it's
America million and and UK billion as
well right because Imperial measurements
isn't it yeah no how many is it can you
tell me nine old money please is it in
stone yeah seventeen pounds and four
ounces so yet Rogen's made this move a
hundred million to increase your market
cap by five billion no matter how many
times that is I know that's a good deal
some of the other interesting things
Spotify pledged to spend five hundred
mil on podcast acquisitions during 2020
now the big chunky that's gone on Rogen
but I don't know what you guys know that
they bought anchor last year uncle ever
without you I can't I uncle Everett I am
Cal Everett anchor like the butter
manufacturing yes and them they bought
every business that has the name
anchored now evolution what is uncle so
Angkor is a podcast hosting platform
it's one of these new ones so you guys
to learn libsyn know you're on blueberry
podcast path one the one that no one
uses that always breaks you want not all
of WordPress users there's never broken
that's a lie don't lie anyways so it's
similar to that but there's this new
wave of podcasts hosting platform like
anchor and what they allow you to do is
actually create and edit your podcasts
in the web app so it's like Garage Band
integrated into so you upload your
single file you can clip stuff you can
add in intros outros upload your media
library and stuff like that see there's
a lot of low-hanging fruit for that and
it's it's mad that it's taken this long
given where we are in the curve with
podcasts for something like that to come
along the and I think this that there's
a lot of stuff related to the the
Spotify Joe Rogan take over
that is pointed out like how how many
gaps there are in like really obvious
gaps that you could easily take over
I've got I got some cool stuff for you
guys to think about now I can't wait to
hear your thoughts on this and also
everybody that's listening I want to
hear what you think this is a big move
we are myself John you're new so far
very interested in terms of both
creators and consumers in the podcasting
space so it's like it is the biggest
news that's probably going to happen for
quite a while
Patrick Pat Davies from value tainment
reckons that within the next five years
we will see a 1 billion dollar podcaster
deal which probably doesn't seem too
ridiculous considering that Rogen's
already managed to get a million sorry a
hundred million for his deal so yeah
what you get with these sorts of hosting
platforms like anchor fm so to not get
to sort of nerdy into it
currently what most podcasts use is the
RSS feed so you upload a file and then
that distributes to wherever you're
listening to this so it distributes to
Apple podcasts and stitcher and so
Spotify actually is one of those but the
way that it works is it has a single
file which is hosted which is unmovable
and unchanging and then that gets sent
out
it's a syndicated to all of these
different platforms right there just an
RSS a glorified RSS reader the what
Spotify is intending on doing now that
it's got anchor as this create anchor
lever well now that it's got that as its
creation platform they have started to
introduce dynamically targeted ads
mid-roll during podcasts so if you ever
listen to true Geordie this is why I
[ __ ] hate and this is a big
implication for people that listen to
podcasts right listen a true Geordie and
half way through they'll just be an
advert for WH Smiths read by some fella
like studio-quality
like have you subscribed to your most
recent edition of gardening world well
why don't you head over to WH Smiths
today and get five pounds off with the
codes true Jordan man so this is
modified this just can interrupt
anyone's podcast and put in their own
advert no no technically no so what will
happen and this is what I think will
happen with
Rogan Rogan was making somewhere between
not including YouTube ad revenue he was
making somewhere between 50 grand and
150 grand per episode on his based on
his CPM he does about 150 million
downloads per month he'll have discounts
on the long term deals people that's
been with him for years like stamps
comic being with him for seven years on
it won't pay as much because he's a
partner there etc etc Busch Kashyap has
been with him for forever yeah I think
Squarespace as well or like Wix or
something so what will happen
I don't think Rogan will be doing any
more pre-roll podcast ads I don't think
he'll need to spot if I might have even
stipulated that he's not allowed to as a
part of this deal but what you will
potentially start to see if you're not
on Spotify Premium is that you will be
targeted with dynamic ads put mid-roll
into the podcast and what this means is
that we're moving from I saw this
analogy online and this is kind of a bit
I wanted to give over to you guys I saw
this analogy on the on the internet
where someone said podcasting at the
moment feels like the Internet in the
early 2000s before everything was
syndicated before there was Google
targeting and tracking pixels and
Facebook ads and retargeting and all
this sort of stuff where people were
just saying that looks like the sort of
site or podcast that my audience listens
to because being honest like modern
wisdom is now venturing into this world
we've got every episode now has got a
sold-out pre-roll ad and a very
fortunate some of the partners I work
with a Laker protein works fit book
tailored athletes Reebok you know like
huge surf shark VPN big companies that
are prepared to pay like great money to
be there but they're just looking at me
and going yeah yeah you you look you
look like yeah yeah young people that's
what young people like young people but
that's not like that's not actually how
targeting works and that's not what
advertisers won like using a [ __ ]
discount code to track sales but what
would you say Johnny if I was like oh
they're most sophisticated format we
have here is that someone's got to enter
this particular bit of tech
well the work the worst thing about it
is that like you relying on the person
reading out an advert for you you know
you're spending all this money and then
the way that's delivered is you
basically send someone a text file they
have to read at the start the podcast
you think well that's like is that hmm
that being said I think that so there's
two types of ads there's dynamic and is
baked in so they're baked in at the post
post read pre-rolls are more expensive
and that's because making the hosts put
it in their own words converts better so
me saying this is what I like about the
protein works because I do this is why I
enjoy the tailored athlete this is why
Surf Shack VPN gets you access to
Netflix is library or what I use it for
bridges the gap between yeah it's not so
jarring not just a dude talking about WH
Smith just like whoa what's that the the
difficulty is that when someone's heard
an advert or even like a baked in thing
as you as you said and it's like oh
remember to go to Tim blog forward slash
wealthfront forward slash Tim forward
slash 500 I'm driving I'm not gonna
remember that URL to go and remember
whatever butchered it but like to come
home and also not not only remember the
URL but also remember that you even
wanted to go and check that out whereas
if you're on a platform you know like
you're on Instagram you'll be
interrupted by an advert and you'll just
go and click on it straight away and
probably leave the platform if it's
something you spot if I might have not
only a dynamic ad they get put in at
particular sections throughout the
podcast but then that ad might be
matched with some sort of visual link
that's what they just heard on I think
I'm the one you only one out of the
three of us that's still on Spotify if
you're any person in the world that
doesn't pay for Spotify yeah you'll have
a you'll have a third-party app I
imagine that blocks the other spot afree
yep there we go do you know why I know
that it's because I have just finished
the life hacks Volume one ultimate life
hacks list
oh that's a few hundred life every life
act that we've ever featured so anything
that you do now I know it because I've
had to go back through and write a
little a little description and what it
is you get released
yeah it's good what is that discover
what's really great
it's a curated playlists of stuff that
you might like it's actually it's one of
the most impressive things about machine
learning and kind of algorithms that
I've found because like such a high
proportion of the songs in release radar
I really like and it's not just like oh
you like young people music so I'll put
some of the young people stuff in it
it's like it's really carefully done
yeah I'd like a podcast release radar
what I could discover weekly like okay
usually it's a it's a selection so if
you think about like I know there's
maybe a list of podcasts at the moment
people maybe only listen to if you take
it forward five years people probably
listen to even more podcasts you got a
curated list of like here are the most
popular releases from the podcasts you
typically listen to you in a list if you
just kind of work through the playlist
but the problem is Johnny I need you to
put more gain unbroke if that's all
right
the problem is that at the moment as a
advertiser or even as a podcast Ella I
don't really know who listens to this
show I have an idea of who listens to
the show based on the Instagram DMS I
can look at the YouTube demos because
they go quite in-depth because you got
to sign up with your full account gender
blah blah blah location but really you
just like shooting blind and just hoping
that the content lands with people and
from a targeting perspective that's
obviously quite a big deal so yeah I
just think I was originally kind of like
oh god it's a big change I don't listen
to podcasts on Spotify I prefer Apple
podcasts because it's native because
it's very very smooth also losing
YouTube and losing the youtube comment
on episodes that I don't comment ever I
enjoy looking at what goes on and I like
to hear how it lands with other people
but you know if Spotify sida
and they're able to then create a
platform which kind of reflects what's
going on there I guess that could be
quite fun yeah I the more I think about
I think the thing I was most sad about
was the video loss of video my mic okay
now by the way lovely the loss of like
because I
like so for example at the latest Elon
Musk Joe Rogan podcast I go I've watched
the video one
I haven't watch the whole thing but I'm
watching the video rather than listening
to it and for some reason God does this
mean that you can only watch the video
on Spotify platform or that you have to
pay a premium Joe Rogan subscription to
see know so he will you will be able to
watch or listen to Joe Rogan for free on
Spotify whether you have Spotify free or
premium however I think if you don't
have spotify premium you will be hit
with dynamic mid-roll ads sure
so I heard rumors that the whole podcast
was going to become a premium one but I
don't think that would be in his in his
announcement about it he says he
stipulates that's not what's happening
right it's yeah and it's I think from
his perspective like he's getting a
hundred million I don't think he's
thought of this as a big like strategic
move of the war between iTunes and
Spotify and Netflix Lee I think he's
just been like yeah 100 million just
does that now exceed the value of what I
would expect to gain from continua cuz
like at the moment his revenue model is
hinged on production whereas it sounds
like with Spotify like as long as you
are exclusive to us and continue just
enjoying like doing what you probably
enjoy doing most in your life then
here's 100 million well regardless of
what you listen on I know you use if
you've kind of moved through a few
different podcasting apps but me and
Johnny uses Apple podcast no matter what
it is that you listen on now you have to
listen on Spotify so it's quite a big
signal from them to just say look this
is the size of our penis our penis is so
large we've taken the biggest podcaster
on the planet not only if we because he
was he wasn't even on Spotify so if you
go on to Spotify now and search Joe
Rogan he hasn't got a single episode
except for the new trailer which is like
just a audio version of the announcement
that you made on on Instagram and um
like for them to say not only gone from
zero to exclusive yes sort of like yeah
and that is a huge move now from my side
again thinking about the fact that we're
starting to slowly monetize this podcast
and dealing with partners that I really
love like Joe's just told the world how
much value is in podcasting and
podcasters like every podcast of it
whatever yours currently charging for
your CPM like treble it because Rogen's
just work just said that he's worth a
hundred million and made Spotify five
billion in two days it's a very smart
move from Spotify it's very much so
clever I wonder whether Apple did a
counter bid or if they were just like Oh
bollocks like we've just lost Joe I
can't see I can't see them doing it man
I could see I could see him going to
YouTube speaking to Google and saying
look and potentially leave him what do
you want to do but he keeps on getting
censored on there so for instance he
can't stream other people's content you
know he's always like Jamie don't put
that up we'll get to how Jamie's always
like don't put that up we'll get taken
down and like yeah youtuber brutal and
and they just don't care cuz even Joe
Rogan is just such a small proportion of
their total traffic that is like
whatever yeah but I'm I'm surprised
about Apple not putting in a not
throwing the height in that ring because
so I just got a year of Apple TV for
free
and Johnny's mentioned how they've
really like thrown in some really
high-profile actors and just plowed
budget into their stuff to really try
and like catch up with Netflix and with
Amazon TV or was it called Amazon Prime
TV or something like so they're really
aggressively diving into these spaces
and for them to just lose someone
exclusively to Spotify when there's this
constant you know the back-and-forth
court cases that Spotify and Apple have
where they wouldn't allow Siri and stuff
like that yeah so because like how do
you listen to Spotify you have to open
the app you can't just be like one what
though an Apple device so like they
don't care yes like like when you Elena
Marshall your Spotify needs it doesn't
really matter what Spotify do like if
they get your own brilliant and when
you're making what was the figure I sent
you ten billion in whatever that's oh
yeah yeah in air pod sales maze wrap
wrap your head around that face so
you're listening to Joe Rogan on Spotify
on your upper life
well I really missed a missing
opportunity here and one day they could
just be like ah sorry Spotify is broken
on up all my phones now oh what a shame
the guy the guy sat in there in the
rocking chair in the corner smoking me
cigar while everyone else has an
argument isn't it it's just like like
wins regardless yeah and then he just he
just as they just as this he just goes
like that and then his driver comes over
and then he leaves just puts his hand in
the air just one finger in the air
raises it and then he departs and
everyone knows when he leaves the entire
building and everyone else disappears
conversations conversations over exactly
game game is over okay so that's that's
my thoughts on Rogen man like I was real
hesitant when it first happened and I
put a story up that got I don't think
I've ever had so many replies like
hundreds of replies to me being sad
about Joe Rogan changing main reason I
was sad was because he promised he'd
never got a platform exclusive on the
show and like people's priorities change
I get that I just hope that it doesn't
damage the quality of the content you
know cuz he's my sort of podcasting role
model he's the person that I've taken
the most inspiration from he's who I
listen to the most consistently across
time and I just don't want the show to
be to be damaged you know that people
don't listen to him because of the
[ __ ] platform they don't listen to
him because of the ads they listen to
him because of the quality of the
content and if this enables him to put
out better content then I'm happy to pay
the price of a little bit more friction
of having to use Spotify
[Music]
you